The first thing I did to solve this problem was to draw a force diagram.
We know the force of gravity is pulling down on the car like we'd expect
and there is some normal force pointing upwards and since the car isn't accelerating vertically,
we know these 2 bit forces must balance each other out perfectly.
And of course, we have the frictional force which we've said is equal to bv²
and we've got the force that the car is producing to make it go forward
and this force is actually produced by the road pushing up on the wheels
by Newton's Third Law the wheels pushed on the ground and the ground pushes back on the wheels
causing the car to move forward,
and we know that if the car is going at its maximum speed and can't go any faster
then these two forces should be perfectly balance too.
We can say that this force here equals this force over here.
Starting with the equation for work, I divide both sides by Δt
and you'll note that this term Δd that change in position over the change in time
Well, that's just the same as velocity
and also over here, work divided by change in time that is just the same thing as power.
We get this nice equation that power is equal to the force pushing the car forward times its velocity.
Now, what's this F equal to?
Well, we said earlier that this F has to perfectly balance out the frictional force.
We know that the frictional force is equal to bv² so we can just plug that in
and multiplying that by the v, we get that the power is equal to bv³.
and summing for velocity, we get that the velocity required to go at a constant speed
at a certain power is equal to the cube root of the power divided by that constant b
and plugging in the numbers we were given.
It turns out that 150 horsepower is equal to 111,000 watts.
We get that the maximum speed you can go is 103.8 m/s,
and if you're curious that is about equal to 232 mi/hr.
Of course, in the real world, we're not just dealing with air friction,
we're dealing with all sorts of friction.
This value might be a little higher that you'd expect,
but if you've got this value, congratulations on solving the problem.